Det är svårt för alla att få lönsamhet i e-handel, även för oss.
Men fysiska butiker är just nu väldigt lönsamma.
Varför?
Det är bra försäljningshållen, det är bra intäkter i förhållande till kostnaderna.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Jenny från Jens till podden.
Jenny har drivit och äger Jens sedan lång tid tillbaka.
Ett bolag som sysslar med manlig skönhet, skulle jag kanske säga.
Hon har också en lite annorlunda bakgrund.
Hon har vunnit SM i boxning två gånger.
Hon är medlem i Mensa.
Följer man lite debatter inom olika grejer så har man säkert sett henne på LinkedIn.
En mycket spännande person att ha med i podden.
Tjena Jenny.
Hej, tack för att jag får vara här.
Tack.
Vi började det här jäkligt roligt.
Du sprang iväg och hämtade lite papper.
Varför hämtar du papper för?
Jag har ofta känslorna utanpå så jag vet redan att jag antagligen kommer att börja gråta.
Ja, du har redan.
Du har redan, under uppsnacket här, torkat ögonen en gång, så var det lite roligt.
Det var liksom ingen hemsk händelse utan det var ju en glad händelse.
Jag har känslorna utanpå.
Alltid.
Och det har alltid varit så?
Funkar det så i förhandlingar också med folk?
Det kan jag göra, men det är inte så mycket känslor inblandade i förhandlingar, utan då är det mer kalla fakta.
Så det är mer när det berör saker som går in på djupet.
Jag fattar.
Eftersom du ändå är den som äger bolaget här, är du alltid en behaglig chef?
Eller kan du bli emotionell även åt andra hållet?
Det kan jag nog bli, det som är i min hjärna kommer ut genom min mun, positivt och negativt.
Då funkar samspelet bäst med personer, medarbetare som förstår det, som förstår att det sällan ligger någonting i det.
Jag är aldrig oträvlig eller så, men jag kan absolut skärpa till rösten.
Det kan jag göra.
Men betyder det att du föredrar andra personer som är emotionella, eller föredrar du människor som är lite lugnare så att de väger upp dig?
Jag föredrar människor som inte ställer spel, utan som säger vad de tänker, och vad som kommer ut om munnen, även om man är glad eller ledsen eller aj, det känselmässiga spelar ingen roll, men jag har enklare att hantera människor som är ärliga och raka.
Raka människor, det kommer man.
Då kan vi göra, då kan vi komma hur långt som helst.
Jag träffade din man här, han jobbar också på bolaget.
Har du svårt, om du nu är den emotionella typen, har du svårt att lämna dig hemma om, ja ni ska vidare till bolaget, ni har bråkat lite hemma, så är det dags att sätta igång och ta ett beslut någonstans.
Ja, vi pratar inte så mycket med varandra här faktiskt.
Nej men absolut, det följer med.
Liksom, jag, bolag och privatliv och så, allting flyter ihop för mig.
Så att barnen är ofta här på jobbet, och jag jobbar ofta hemma också.
Så att allting flyter ihop.
Jag delar inte upp det.
Exakt, jag upplever att du, nu känner inte jag dig, men jag har ju ändå läst på lite om det här innan och lyssnat på det.
Du, jag får känslan att du funkar lite grann på samma sätt som jag, att jobbet är liksom inte såhär.
Det är livet.
Ja exakt, det här är inte någonting man ska göra under två år, och man orkar inte heller fejka.
Nej.
Nej, utan det är som det är, och så får jobbet på något sätt anpassas efter det, och så hoppas man att det går bra typ.
Precis, nej men precis så är det.
Jag tror inte på att dela upp jobb och fritid och så, jag tror inte att människan mår bra av det, jag tror att det är mycket därifrån utbrändheten kommer och sådär, att man försöker...
Prio ditt liv måste vara det som är prio just nu, och är det någonting på jobbet som är prio, då är det det som är prio.
Och är det någonting privat som är prio, så är det det som är prio även på arbetstid.
Så att liksom man måste reda hit det.
Tror du att det är svårt för kolleger att acceptera det eller vara en D?
Det är ju en väldigt behaglig filosofi så länge allting är bra.
Men när det inte är bra så är det en ganska jobbig...
Det är samma sak som att vara rak.
Det är jättehärligt med folk som är raka så länge det är behagligt, men det är inte jättehärligt när man faktiskt har betett sig uruselt.
Nej, det är väl hur mycket man kan ta åt båda hållen.
Men jag tänker...
Jag vet faktiskt inte vad jag tänker.
Det är bara som det är.
Det är så du driver företag och då får man anpassa sig till det på något sätt.
För du äger bolaget till 100 procent.
Jag äger 91 procent av biologen och min man äger 9 procent.
Så jag behövde låna pengar om honom en gång för att fortsätta tillväxtresan och då blev det så att han bara fick aktier till slut.
Jag fattar, det är rimligt.
Kan du berätta om bolaget lite kort?
Bara så att vi tar det i början.
Ja men bolaget heter Gens.
Vi säljer skönhetsprodukter för män, hygienprodukter och livsdelsprodukter.
Vi har varit igång i 20 år ungefär.
Vi började som e-handlare och därefter gick vi över till att öppna butiker redan 2007.
Vi öppnade första butik och nu har vi tre butiker.
Vi säljer i många olika länder, men vi har bara fyra eller fem lokala sajter som vi jobbar med.
Men vi skickar till de flesta länder i världen.
Jag kan tycka att det är skumt på två olika sätt.
Dels är det ju skumt för 20 år sedan att öppna e-handel.
Dels är det ju extremt skumt att öppna e-handel inom manlig skönhet på något sätt.
Och dels är det lite skumt att du som kvinna öppnar e-handel inom manlig skönhet för 20 år sedan.
För att jag vet inte ens om det konceptet fanns då.
Nej, det fanns inte.
Och det var himla bra och skönt och det var en ren, om vi går tillbaka till de här frågorna då, så det var ju en ren bara, vi funderar inte så mycket på det, vi bara räknar var är luckan?
Var kan man tjäna pengar?
Och då är det...
Och då tänkte ni på detta av alla gamla ämnen.
Ja, för att då för 20 år sedan så det fanns inte så mycket för män överhuvudtaget.
Samtidigt som män, liksom kvinnor, har komplex för allt möjligt.
Det kan vara håravfall, hår på ryggen, svettningar.
Det finns hur mycket som helst.
Men det fanns då nästan ingenting för män.
Utan om man brydde sig om sig själv för 20 år sedan och var man, då var man bög.
Och bög, det var inget positivt ord för 20 år sedan.
Utan det var verkligen någonting som var negativt laddat.
Och samtidigt hade millenniebubblan precis sprukit it-bubblan.
Och så slog jag ihop en med mina två kusiner och var en av våra programmerare.
Och så sa han, jag tror vi behöver göra någonting online om vi ska slå oss ihop.
Och då gjorde vi det och så funderade vi.
Och så bara, det här med hudvård för män, det kommer att bli stort.
Vi satsar på det.
Okej, fick ni bara det som en random idé?
Det fanns ingen såhär, det är så jävla oväntad, jag tycker det är en väldigt oväntad twist.
För att nu kan man, absolut, jag fattar att folk kommer väga ihop det här.
Och de kommer tänka att det där började för några år sedan.
Absolut, men 20 år sedan är ganska länge sedan i den här.
Ja det är det, men det har också gått i olika trender i det här.
Så att det började för hudvård för män för 20 år sedan.
Då fanns det faktiskt en liten trend.
Det fanns ett tv-program då som hette Fab Five.
Ja just det.
Det är det det började med, att vi då kände att ni började.
Så körde vi igång där och sen det här med hudvård, det höll egentligen bara två och tre år.
Sen därefter så insåg vi att hudvård är inte det viktigaste för män, utan det är rakningen.
Och fungerar inte rakningen, om man har en problem med inåtväxande hårströmmar eller rakirritation eller någonting annat, då spelar det ingen roll vad hudvården är, för att du har ett sånt, återigen prioriteringen, det är liksom, fungerar inte rakningen så fungerar ingenting.
Så då växlade vi om till vårt rakning istället och då samtidigt kom det faktiskt en vårt rakningstrend.
Och det var jättestort med rakknivar och rakblad och säkerhetssyvlar och raksgum och raktvålar runt 2007, 2008, 2009.
Och då öppnade vi också en barbershop här i Hessenborg.
Och sen övergick den trenden så småningom i en skäggtrend 2014.
2013-2014 så pekade den 2015.
Och därefter så gledde trenden över i en nischparfymtrend.
Och den började vi med direkt vid skäggtrendens slit.
Och den pekade ju just nu.
Parfymtrenden.
Den är gigantisk.
Fan, jag vill inte väva vidare, det är så många frågor på vägen där egentligen.
Dels tycker jag det är sjukt intressant när folk startar.
Vi ska också komma in på dina kusiner, men det är sjukt intressant när folk startar eller driver bolag där de själva inte är kunden.
Jag tycker det är väldigt spännande eftersom jag är min egen huvudkund och ganska många av dem jag träffar startar ju någonting för att de har ett väldigt stort intresse av det eller de liksom hittar ett problem i det när de själva har varit i det.
Men du är ju lite utifrån i den här.
Vad är fördelarna med det eller vad är nästa delarna?
Då för 20 år sedan, det fanns ju ingen man som kunde detta.
Alltså kunde hudbron och liksom skönhet och vilka lösningar finns det.
Utan det behövdes en kvinna för att kunna göra det, som är insatt i de här sakerna.
Men sen var också mina kusiner, de var ju målgruppen för bolaget och jag var nog mer bjuden som en sidekick för att sköta administrationen kanske.
Jag hade pluggat juridik och jag var bra på ekonomi och då kände de nog att det var en trygghet att ha med mig.
Jag fattar, men kvinnor ligger så monumentalt mycket före oss att de behöver en kompetens i detta.
Ja men 100 procent, för kvinnors stora intresse på denna planet kan jag känna ibland skönhetsfrågor.
Och det är så små enkla medel man kan använda för att justera problem som många män lider av.
Och det hade en kvinna löst det på fem sekunder, men mannen vet inte ens om att det finns.
Så då får man liksom branda om lite grejer och sen läsa det.
Är manlig skönhet, är det etablerat nu liksom?
Ja det tycker jag.
Jag vet fortfarande om jag skulle kalla det skönhet, men jag gör det ändå, jag gör det ändå.
Därför att skönhet är fortfarande inte ett manligt ord, utan det är mer hygien eller att ta hand om sig liksom, så.
Att bara se välvårdad dit egentligen.
Jag har benat det här med min flickvän många gånger.
Jag har ju en grov ångest över att män blir alltmer välvårdade och liksom tar hand om sig själva, klär sig väl, kammar sig väl och sånt där.
För jag brukar tänka att jag är den sista gubben på något sätt.
Jag tycker att det är en av de bästa fördelarna vi har som killar, att vi blir aldrig bedömda för att vi bara är slashasar på något sätt.
Och jag trivs väldigt väl i att bara vara så här.
Jag har liksom ingen åsikt om det och har verkligen inte det och tycker att det är så skönt att jag får ha så.
Så jag är så rädd för att om 20 år så blir det här en faktor i att man ska sitta vid ett förhandlingsbord och så kommer folk att plötsligt tänka va, ser han ut sådär?
Va fan, kan vi inte bara pausa här?
Kan jag få leva i min lilla bubbla ett tag till?
Alltså jag tror att det finns plats för alla och och det finns en marknad för alla och det finns en kvinna för alla.
Så skulle jag också säga, alltså du träffar ju min man där nu nu är han kanske lite tillfixad idag, men han är ju precis som du.
Och jag kan ibland säga män som jag tycker är överfixade och det tycker inte jag är, alltså som kvinna tycker inte jag att det är attraktivt.
Så att, och åt andra hållet också kanske, men det liksom, det finns, man ska vara den man är och trivs med och då blir det bra.
Alltså då blir man, då får man vänner och man får en mening i sitt liv.
Det är ändå det som räknas, att man har ett meningsfullt liv.
Och det kommer du bara få om man är sig själv.
Vem du än är.
Ja, jag vet ju att du, eller fan vi hoppar inte in där än, vi börjar med dina krisiner, helvete vad många grejer det är.
När jag skrev till Jenny inför detta så skrev jag ju ner frågor, men jag har ju 800 frågor till, kan ju vara bra att veta.
Jag tycker ni får lyssna in de andra poddarna här också, det finns väldigt mycket information vi kommer missa om Jenny i det här tyvärr, för att inte folk ska zooma ut helt.
Men du har två kusiner, varför fick de lämna?
Jag tror inte att de var så jätteintresserade av detta område, de hade andra företagsidéer.
Samtidigt som jag, då, back in the days, så jobbade jag som skattejurist och jag kände att jag hade kommit till vägseende på den karriären.
Det bara följde sig så väl att de ville bli utköpta och jag ville köpa ut.
Och då gjorde jag det 2010.
2010, var det en stor investering för dig?
Nej, det var det inte för att det hade, bolaget hade gått dåligt i några år för ingen hade fokuserat på det.
Och bolag som man inte fokuserar på, de går dåligt.
Så att, nej men jag tror jag köpte ut dem för 910 och annat.
Var det då du började fokusera på det?
Ja, då började jag fokusera och jobba det hela tiden med det då.
Jag släppte mitt andra jobb och började hela tiden.
Och då lägger man ner mycket tid och kraft och driver det som ett projekt.
Med att intäkterna ska in, då intäkterna ska upp och kostnaderna ska ner.
Och det är liksom mitt mantra och det låter så...
Smart.
Inte väldigt enkelt, men det är precis så det är.
Intäkterna ska upp, kostnaderna ska ner.
Och då börjar det med det.
Och då händer ju det.
Det tog 7-8 månader innan vi bara såg utväxling.
Intäkterna gick upp, kostnaderna gick ner.
Man ska gasa och bromsa samtidigt.
Du har ju varit entreprenör ganska länge.
Du har drivit detta ganska länge.
Har du fortfarande passion för bolaget i sig eller är detta bara en livsstil nu?
Jag har passion för entreprenörskap.
Jag älskar att driva bolag.
Jag älskar att göra just det, få upp intäkterna, ner kostnaderna.
Och det är som en tävling för mig och jag tycker det är jättekul.
Men jag har mer och mer, ju äldre jag blir, och det här liksom kanske är sådant som man inte riktigt pratar om, men mer och mer så tappar jag intresset för ledarskap.
Och det är ju ett handicap när man är vd.
För när jag var yngre så tyckte jag att ledarskap var jättekul och jag läste allt man kunde läsa.
Och ledarskap var också ett sätt att liksom, du vet, göra karriär eller komma upp sig och bli chef och hela biten.
Och jag tycker att den miljön har förändrats mycket de senaste åren.
Kanske är det för att det är ett större ålderskap mellan mig och medarbetarna nu.
Så att jag har svårt att förstå dem som är 23-24 år gamla.
Jag är fel ledare för dem.
Förstår du deras motivation eller bara förstår du dem?
Vi har olika sätt att kommunicera.
Om jag inte sätter en hjärtemoji så är jag arg, uppenbarligen.
Det blir många missförstånd.
Det låter som att det har hänt.
Och den här rakheten som jag uppskattar, det uppskattar inte en 23-åring.
Så att säga.
Det är där jag börjar krokna, i så fall om jag skulle säga någonting.
Men att driva bolag är ju super, super kul.
Men du är fortfarande vd?
Jag är fortfarande vd.
Och du vill fortfarande vara vd?
Tills vidare.
Jag tänker så här.
Jag ska faktiskt sätta ut en annons idag på en tjänst som jag kallar Chief of Staff.
Som är som du är Chief of Staff i Vita huset.
Och där en person bara driver den dagliga verksamheten och handlar om all personal.
Och jag kan fokusera på att sälja och det kreativa.
Som jag gör bäst.
Men för ni är ändå ett gäng människor.
Hur mycket är ni?
Vi kan väl vara 25-30 med lager och butiker och hela fadrullen.
Och kanske 30-35 när jag tänker efter.
Och har ni tre olika ställen?
Vi har tre butiker, ett lager och så här kontoret.
Det blir ju, det är dessutom lite olika personligheter på olika ställen.
Det är verkligen olika.
Och det är också en utmaning för ledarskapet.
Att ha ett sådant spektrum i de människor man jobbar med.
Det är ju alltifrån extremt väl utbildad CFO, till en person kanske på laget eller i butik, som inte ens vill vara där för arbetsförmedlingen har satt dem där.
Och att få alla de här att dra åt samma håll, det är en utmaning ibland.
Nu pratar du nästan som att du inte vill ha hand om personal för att det skulle vara en hög utmaning.
Är det?
Får du ta, vissa av er kan få ett födda till det.
Om jag lyssnar på resten av din story så låter det som att utmaning är en intressant grej.
Men inte i det här fallet, inte av människor.
Det tar för mycket energi.
Jag är också en relationsmönstrar, jag tycker det är kul med människor och relationer.
Det är så mycket i ledarskapet som inte handlar om att vara vän med varandra, utan det handlar om att driva ett bolag framåt.
Om du då är en relationsmönstrar så blir det inte riktigt bra alla gånger.
Jag köper det.
Det kan bli såklart tufft.
Finns det någonting som jag tycker bara är intressant?
Jag personligen kan tycka att det som är absolut tuffast är när det finns konflikt mellan medarbetare.
Inte kanske att jag har konflikt med folk.
Det tycker jag inte är så jättehemst eller att säga till eller att vad det nu skulle behöva vara att säga upp någon.
Det är inte det hemska men när det finns ett gnissel mellan människor i min organisation, jag kan liksom inte sova på grund av det.
Så länge det är italat så kan jag hantera det, hantera konflikten mellan andra människor.
Men när det är någonting som puttrar under ytan och det är ingen som säger någonting, det är bara att person A gillar inte person B och det blir grupperingar eller sådär.
Och återigen, ingen säger någonting.
Då är det jättesvårt för då är det ett företagskutredproblem.
Och företagskutredproblem, på något vis så kan det ibland sätta sig i väggarna.
Man måste bli av med det direkt och rensa upp det direkt.
Ja, men du nämnde också att du hade lite knepigare att hantera.
Det är ingre människor.
Kan du inte bara anställa folk som är över 30?
Jo, men det är det.
Eller det är någon roll liksom.
Jag börjar gå mot det nu.
Eller så är det kanske bara bättre att man lämnar överledarskap.
Ja, okej då.
Men måste man ha folk som är 20?
Jag vet man ska inkludera alla, man ska ha alla åldersspann, absolut.
Men kan du inte bara ha folk som är över 35?
Jo, kanske.
Det är ju bara att det blir ett himla dammigt företag.
För de här unga, de är ju också så pigga och glada och de kommer hård vett, de har väldigt mycket mer energi.
Okej, fair enough.
Vi nämnde ju här i början att du blir lite emotionell ibland och liknande, men jag har hört dig framförallt prata om manlig hälsa och ni pratar även om psykologi och liknande hos män och sånt där.
Och där har jag hört dig bli väldigt emotionell.
Varför?
För jag tycker det är nog att, ja men nu börjar jag ju där.
Ja men jag har ett stort hjärta för insatta personer och just det du pratar om, det är ju att en stor del av självmord till exempel begås av män.
Nu kommer jag inte ihåg siffran, men det är ju jättemånga.
Det är 75 procent av alla självmord begås av män och att män har mycket mycket större psykisk ohälsa än vad kvinnor har.
Och det är ju en utveckling som har skett de senaste åren och det börjar redan i skolan hos pojkar, att de inte hänger med.
Skolan är liksom på något vis anpassad efter kvinnor och det är ju konstigt eftersom det, om vi inte sätter tillbaka historiskt, det är ju männen som har byggt skolan, men ändå.
Jag tror bara att det är liksom samhället vi går in i nu, vi håller på att tappa en stor grupp av småpojkar som växer upp i tolvåringar och det här är inte bra för någon, framförallt inte pojkarna.
Och det berör mig mycket.
Liksom det berör mig också, du kan ta äldrevården i Sverige, den berör mig jättemycket.
Och jag vet att alla har olika hjärtefrågor, vissa bryr sig om klimatet, vissa bryr sig om dittan och detta, men min hjärtefråga är de här frågorna, jag tycker de är jätteviktiga.
Men blir du lika emotionellt involverad så fort det handlar om ordetvis, om det handlar om barn som är utsatta eller om äldrevård som du säger?
Ja men det kan ju bli djur också.
Ja men det blir det ju, jag tycker det är superjobbigt.
Men det är ändå bra för jag har en stark driftkraft, så det blir att man på något vis engagerar sig ett tag i det.
Så förra året så gjorde vi på Gens och vi har alltid haft att all vår väljarenhet går till Prostata Cancerförbundet och vi har två dagar om året någonting där vi skänker, jag kommer inte ihåg om det är alla intäkter eller efter intäkter, jag kommer faktiskt inte ihåg siffran hur mycket vi skänker.
Men förra året så växlade vi om det så skänkte vi hela tiden, och då delas man till MIND som jobbar med mäns psykiska ohälsa.
Ja det kommer ju knappast bli mindre.
Nej det kommer inte bli mindre, det är liksom den här ensamheten, ensamheten bland äldre och liksom den här, du vet när de har studerat, det här är en amerikansk studie som har läst det, när de analyserar självmordsbreven i USA från överlevande faktiskt, män som har försökt ta livet av sig, så är de vanligaste orden är alone, useless, no purpose, sådana ord.
Jag kan absolut se det, det är bara, det blir väldigt lätt att släta över också eftersom de som oftast är, för människor har varit de starkare.
Men också att de som sitter ensamma sitter ju ofta framför en dator och då blir de på något sätt troll då, eller vad man ska säga.
Så blir det en grupp som man snarare ska se som fiende.
Det hade varit fört om, 75% av alla de som hade tagit livet av sig hade varit kvinnor.
Då hade folk varit på barrikad med.
Men det är inte det ni, och jag tycker det är så udda.
Ja, det här är spännande.
Eller sorgligt men spännande.
Jag har också hört dig prata om någonting som jag tycker är extremt intressant.
Du har pratat öppet om facket och pratat kritiskt om det.
Och det pratade typ ingen om någonsin.
Nej, men det är för att jag tror att många har felaktig bild av facket.
Många tror att det är någon rättvist, organisation eller...
Ja men, vi har inte kollektivavtal på djent.
Och ibland kan jag känna på intervjuer att folk tycker att det är lite mysko att man inte har det.
Eller att det är ett suspekt företag som försöker lura sina anställda och dittan och dattan.
Och det är en bild som på något vis bara har växt fram i media eller så.
Och jag har inte jättebra erfarenheter av facket.
Jag tycker sällan det bryr sig om sina medlemmar överhuvudtaget.
Det handlar om att det handlar om makt och det handlar om att kväva företagande eller entreprenörskap på ett negativt sätt och ett väldigt negativt teologi.
Man kan bara följa Tesla-konflikten så tycker jag man har svart på vitt ärr.
Det handlar om makt.
Det handlar inte om vad som är bäst för bolaget eller bäst för medarbetarna eller bäst för Sverige ensågång.
Det handlar om att pissa revir och visa vem som har makten.
Blir du aldrig nervös att du ska bli exempel?
Nej, jag tycker att jag navigerar det ganska bra.
Jag är jurist och jag har bra juridisk hjälp.
Jag sköter det alltid.
Personalkonflikter sköter jag alltid, by book.
Det är till lagens sista bokstav.
Det är synd på ett vis för att jag hade gärna velat hantera vissa saker mer mänskligt istället för att gå på lagtext.
Till exempel så hade jag gärna berättat för människor varför de blev uppsagda.
Eller redan långt innan de blev uppsagda säger jag att det här är ett problem, att du har det här beteendet gentemot dina medarbetare.
Men som det är ni som lagtexten skriver så kan du inte säga någonting.
Så jag tycker att det är kontraproduktivt.
Men det kan ju inte finnas en enda arbetsgivare som inte nämner problemet.
Jag nämner inte ett problem någon enda gång, tyvärr.
För då åker jag ju på det sen.
När jag väl sen kanske, jag har gjort det från början.
Så jag har ju lärt mig den hårda vägen.
Att kanske från början sagt till att du kan inte göra såhär eller att du kan inte ha en attityd en problem mot dina kollegor.
Sen när jag så småningom insett att det här går inte.
Är det så det funkar?
Jag känner mig alltid som en jävla barnpojj.
Om du då säger upp någon så är det ju personliga skäl.
Så att säga, du får inte säga upp någon på personliga skäl och då är det skadestånd mot arbetsgivaren.
Trots att det kan vara fråga om mobbing eller vad som helst.
Alltså en medarbetare som mobbar en annan.
Då behöver jag köpa ut den.
Jag behöver köpa ut mobbarna.
Och istället så blir det ju så att när jag ser en sådan situation, så arrangerar jag ju istället by the book enligt lagtext, så att den här personen blir uppsagt på grund av arbetspris.
Ja exakt.
Och jag tycker det är ledsamt, för hade vi mycket hellre haft i år igen en rapkommunikation och sagt att vi tolererar inte sånt här.
Och så kanske den personen hade kunnat vara kvar, kunnat förändra sitt beteende, hade kunnat eller gå vidare till en annan arbetsplats och kanske få sig en funderare varför man blev uppsagt.
Jaha, vad märkligt att det funkar på det sättet.
Jag har ju som tur är sluppit relativt mycket konflikt, men det är klart att vi har haft konflikter också, men ja, fan vad sjukt.
Ja, där lärde jag mig någonting.
Men det är en sådan sak, jag tycker generellt sett att arbetsrätten är inte svåra att navigera, men jag tycker det är synd att man ska behöva navigera det överhuvudtaget, där det varit mycket bättre att bara vara rätt fram.
Och sen tycker jag som sagt att facket, man ibland kan råka ut för aktivister, för någon som har en politisk agenda, där det handlar om att som sagt kväva entreprenören och trycka till entreprenören istället för att faktiskt titta på medlemmen och se hur få den här medlemmen att gå vidare till en bättre situation.
Ja exakt, det är det det borde handla om.
Har du någonsin fått folk som inte vill börja på jobbet för att du inte är med i facket eller har kollektivitet?
Det har hänt en gång.
Och då är det ju nästan bra att det inte blir en anställning.
För då har vi så olika mentalitet i så fall.
Du har ju drivit bolaget i 20 år.
Och marknaden har ju ändrats relativt mycket under den tiden.
Och jag gissar att de första 10-15 åren så var ni typ ledande i Sverige och satte trenderna.
Jag bara förutsätter det utan att ha någon koll på marknaden.
Men att nu på sista åren så har ni börjat få konkurrens och kanske framförallt utomlands.
Alla säger ju alltid lyko och liknande grej men det är ju trender som sprids på TikTok eller Instagram eller vad som helst.
Så jag gissar att det kommer utifrån.
Hur hanterar man det?
Och framförallt hur hanterar du det när du har du har liksom vant dig vid en roll och ett segment?
Ett segment, exakt.
Ja och du vet att det här är min roll i värdekedjan på något sätt och helt plötsligt kommer sjukt mycket nya konkurrenter och sätt att navigera.
Hur fan löser man det liksom?
Du har ju rätt i det att det är liksom svårt.
Men vi har jobbat mycket från början med ägna varumärken och jag tror att i alla verksamheter, i alla branscher så kommer det att handla om en annan sak eller två saker.
Men för vår del handlar det om bruttomaginal.
Att vi måste se till att vi har bättre bruttomaginal än andra för att kunna leva på samma nivå vad gäller marknadsföring och sådär eftersom de på det punkt två har så mycket större volymer.
Så att antingen handlar det om volym eller så handlar det om bruttomaginal.
Och egen med att vi är så små då jämfört till exempel med Lyco så har vi en möjlighet att vara mycket mycket snabbare på fötterna.
Och vi har också en lite annorlunda affärsmodell.
Som ger oss, alltså 30% av vår omsättning kommer från ägna varumärken till exempel.
Och de styror ställer vi över och placerar hur vi vill.
Och det ger oss en styrka som många andra inte har.
Och det ger oss en möjlighet också att styra kunden.
Alltså äger man kunden så kan man också berätta för kunden vad kunden ska köpa.
Och det är vår fördel helt klart.
Och då kan vi ge bra erbjudande.
Vi kan skräda sig i program.
Vi kan göra allt möjligt.
Och plus att många av de varumärken som vi säljer är också så små så att de hade drunknat hos Lyko till exempel.
Man har inte fått plats i Ätom hos Lyko men vi kan höja dem.
Och de får synas mycket hos oss och det gör också att de väljer oss.
Okej, men det köper jag.
Räknas ni som kreddiga i era värld?
Ja det gör vi.
Man vill synas och se då vet man att man är godkänd liksom.
Ja men precis, man får också tänka på att försäljningen har också skiftat för bara fem, eller jag säger tre år sedan så skedde ju en försäljning, en införsäljning av en parfym, den skedde i vår butik.
Men nu kan införsäljningen ske på TikTok av en influencer någonstans.
Och det gör ju att tillgängligheten av en viss parfym är otroligt viktig, att man kan få köpa den överallt.
Och det är klart, det är en marknadsförskjutning som drabbar oss.
Helt klart.
Vilket gör, återigen då går jag tillbaka, att man måste satsa på de egna varumärkena, du måste ha kontroll på de varumärkena.
Det är där län som heter, och det är där framtiden är.
Jag tror att vi har ju inte bara konkurrens av Lyko, utan vi har ju också konkurrens av varumärkena själva, som säljer direkt till kund.
Och det är framtiden för multistore som man säger så.
Man kan debattera den, men man måste ha en rygggrad av egna varumärken.
Är ni lite körda i att växa för mycket, för att om ni skulle gå in i för mycket trend eller för mycket mot det unga klientelet, så på något sätt så den här urkunden som ni kanske har, de kanske inte vill förknippas med en 18-åring som kollar TikTok, utan de vill vara lite mogen och kurerad.
Precis, så är det och det är någonting vi diskuterar här varenda dag, om vem är kunden och vi vet ju väldigt mycket väl vem vår urkund är.
Men det är också, då kommer man in mot, när vi återigen pratar 23-åriga medarbetare, de har svårt att förstå en 40-årig man, en 23-årig kvinna som spenderar sin tid på TikTok.
Hon har svårt att sedan skapa material som att räkna en 40-årig man.
Ja men det köper jag verkligen.
Hur gör man då för att, eller drivs du av expansion och tillväxt, eller tänker du att du drivs av att du har ett härligt bolag, eller hur gör du för att expandera då?
Ja, det är ju den stora frågan.
Nu har vi precis öppnat en butik i Stockholm till exempel.
Det tror jag mycket på.
Just nu, jag säger verkligen just nu för att det förändras i vartannat år ungefär.
Just nu tror jag på fysiska butiker och expansionen genom det.
Jag tror det är svårt för alla att få lönsamhet i e-handel, även för oss.
Men fysiska butiker är just nu väldigt väldigt lönsamma.
Varför?
Det bara är det.
Det är bra försäljning i förhållande.
Det är bra intäkter i förhållande till kostnaderna.
Faktiskt.
Ja, absolut.
Och det bygger varumärke och det bygger top of mind.
Jobbar ni med att få in rätt kund, eller snarare, jobbar ni med att hålla ut det fel kunde ur butikerna?
Nej det gör vi inte.
Men vi riktar vår marknadsföring till en viss specifik kund och sen kommer en annan kund in så är den kunden också jässligt välkommen.
Vi riktar vår marknadsföring utslitande mot män.
Men ändå är det ju 30 procent kvinnor som handlar hos oss.
Ja men det är väl ändå rimligt.
Det måste ju vara samma sak tvärtom att killar köper grejer åt sina flickvänner också.
Jag förstår.
Det är väl ganska självklart men du har aldrig varit sugen på att gå mot det kvinnliga.
Nej men jag har fått frågan många gånger, men det har jag inte varit.
Jensen dwee, ja jag vet inte.
Vi hade ett aprilskämt en gång när vi döpte om jäns till hents.
Men nej, det är så hög konkurrens.
Och vet du vad, jag kan inte den branschen.
Jag kan inte kvinnogrejer.
Jag är den som är här på kontor och hela företaget, jag är den som kan minst om utseende för kvinnor.
Det måste ju vara ändå ganska, för traditionellt sett, och om vi kollar på marknaden så är det ju en ybermajoritet av alla smink, parfym, hudvård och liknande butiker och kedjor och gehandlare är ju mot kvinnor.
Det måste ju vara hyggligt rimligt för en sådan aktör att ta in er och helt plötsligt addera den manliga kundgruppen.
Har ni fått den sortens proppå från en industriell spelare?
Nej, aldrig.
Nej, men jag tänker, det låter, det skulle ju låta rimligt.
Men jag tänker, jag jag sitter ju i styrelsen för Oskar Jacobson och jag tänker, skulle dom börja med kvinnor och kläder?
Alltså det känns bara, jag vet inte, jag har bara suttit där i ett halvår så jag vet inte hur diskussionerna har varit för hit.
Men, på något vis så urvattnar det ju också konceptet då.
Och om du med gymkompaniiet skulle börja med, jag vet inte, någonting random.
Det är liksom, det är en annan kund, det är samma kanske vad, nej, nej.
Jag kan ta ett exempel, vi började till exempel med yogautrustning, vilket kan låta jätte relevant för gymutrustning.
Vi säljer ju allting som finns på ett gym liksom, men.
Men det är ju en annan kund.
Exakt, och det är en helt annan marknadsföring, det är helt annan känsla, det är en helt annan, exakt.
Och andra insökskanaler säkert, och det är en helt, det är en parallell värld, fast de ligger så nära man.
Det var en bedrövlig satsning som vi lade ner snabbt.
Ja, bedrövliga satsningar har man gjort.
Exakt, men så när blir ni uppköpta av Oscar Jacobson och de börjar sälja?
Nej, det blev vi nog inte.
Men tänker du att du ska driva bolaget i 20 år till?
Ja, men det tänker jag.
Men det kommer att förändras mycket.
Det är inte, bolaget kommer inte att se ut, vi är redan, ja men det morfar ju hela tiden in i någonting annat beroende på vad marknaden tar vägen.
Till exempel då, alltså förra året så skulle vi släppa en parfymlinja.
Och när jag räknade efter vad det skulle binda för kapital på balansräkningen, att sätta igång en parfymlinja så insåg jag att jag kan lika bra starta en fabrik för att det kostar lika mycket.
Så då gjorde jag det, så vi har köpt hem alla maskinerna så nu går vi in i tillverkningsfasen.
Vad coolt.
Och ställer oss på ytterligare ett ben.
Och kommer ta in externa kunder på det.
Så att bolaget förändras och jag tycker mycket, jag inspireras av många andra företagare, dig bland annat, jag tycker väldigt mycket om dina LinkedIn-inlägg.
Men också du kan ta en sådan som LVMH-koncernen.
Hur mycket de adderar och säljer av och stänger ner och öppnar upp.
Och hela tiden hur du, den koncernen morfar in i någonting annat.
Och att stå stilla och bara hålla på med samma sak och kräma ur så mycket du kan av den där resultaträkningen som du har statiskt.
Jag tror inte på det långsiktigt.
Då kan du överleva en trend.
Men du kommer inte att överleva långsiktigt.
Och jag får ofta den frågan faktiskt, nu hoppar jag vidare, jag får ofta den frågan, varför har han inte bättre EBITDA på tjänst?
Vem ställer den frågan till?
Gud, så får vi veta.
Går folk fram så på gatan?
Det är aldrig någon som går fram till mig på gatan.
Det är ibland, jag är inte investerare hos mig, det är aldrig någon som vill investera.
Men det är ju business-människor.
Det är de styror jag sitter och har suttit i så att jag kan lätt styrsordföra och säga Jens är ett himla fint biolog men ni har dålig EBITDA för vi har bara typ 5-6% för er.
Fan jag har två.
Och ja, det är möjligt såhär men vi bygger ju också för framtiden.
Så jämför de oss kanske med en annan konkurrent i branschen och så säger jag, fast de bygger ju inte för framtiden.
De krämar ur allt ur sin resultaträkning, här och nu.
De har inte en enda post på balansräkningen som är för framtiden.
Men vi bygger ju hela tiden våra egna varumärken och de är inte upptagna, man får inte ta upp dem på balansräkningen till en enda krona för det är egenupparbetat goodwill och det får man inte ta upp.
Men om du tar vårt varumärke, Benjamin Barber, de sätter 12 miljoner och det liksom, det finns inte upptaget någonstans och vi har ju två personer som jobbar typ heltid med det.
Så det är klart att vi har en dålig ebit där också, men den dagen jag säljer det där varumärket, då ramlar du ju in på resultaträkningen.
Men tills dess är det osynligt.
Jag delar den filosofin lite, man använder sitt bolag nästan som ett verktyg för att hantera marknaden på något sätt.
Inte så att man ska krämma ur det liksom, utan snarare så här, jag använder det här för att segla och se vart jag hamnar.
Ja, precis.
Men när du hamnade i styrelsen för Oskar Jakobsson, så jag bara förutsätter att alla vet vad de gör, men tänk typ kostymer.
Så vad är det de söker efter?
Vad var det de ville ha när de tog in dig?
Jag tror att jag tillför en annan dimension.
Jag är den enda externa styrsledamuten.
Det är ju väldigt smickrande.
Ja, det är nog olika från bolag till bolag vad man söker.
Innan Oskar Jakobsson satt jag i en styrse som heter Räckesbutiken som gör balkongräcken här i Engelholm och poolräcken och så där.
Och i det fallet så tror jag att jag kom in där för att jag är en bra länk mellan grundaren som skulle lämna och en stor ägare som hade köpt bolaget och den själva överlämningen till några år att göra.
Och då tror jag att jag har haft två externa vd's inne på Gens och har mycket erfarenheter kring det.
Så det var liksom, jag var en bra match för att sy ihop alla människor där.
Och sen när det gäller Oskar Jacobson så gör jag mig själv lite förvånad när jag fick frågan men jag tror att de gillar att jag är i typsamma bransch fast i skönhetsbranschen.
Så det är en kompletterande bransch.
Skönhet och fashion går väldigt nära.
Beauty och fashion går väldigt mycket hand i hand.
Det är samma trender, det är samma kunder oftast.
Jag är väldigt duktig på omvärldsbevakning.
Jag läser tre tidningar om dagen, lyssnar på en miljard poddar.
Min stora go-to-tidning är Business of Fashion, som är en global dagens industri för fashionverksamheten.
Jag är bra på strategi, jag är bra på att se mönster och hur mönsterna förändras.
Det är ju det du behöver för att kunna ta action och lägga, fundera över hur bolaget behöver positionera sig redan ny för en förändring som kanske händer om ett eller två eller tre år.
Om ni vill köpa in Jenny Rydström som styrelse för...
Nej, det räcker jag inte som lösning, men tack ändå.
Du frågade vad de ville ha i mig.
Jag kanske läser en stor skrytparada här, men så är det.
Jag är bra på omvärldsbevakning, jag är bra på att se mönster och hur mönster förändras.
Jag är bra på att anpassa mig efter det.
Har du en styrelse?
Jag hade en styrelse faktiskt.
Var det i samband med att du hade externa VDS?
Ja men det började redan innan dess.
När vi omsatte 30 miljoner så gick jag ett styrelseprogram för att jag insåg att om vi ska ta det här vidare så måste vi på något vis.
Jag var också lite fascinerad av all styrelse.
Var det alls uttryck med en styrelse?
Visste inte vad man skulle göra i en styrelse.
Då kom jag i kontakt med en som sen blev min mentor, som heter Kristina Järring, som var styrelseordförande.
Hon var professionell styrelseledamot.
Hon hjälpte mig att bygga en styrelse.
Det blev väldigt bra.
Alltså jag tror någonstans along the way mot ett större bolag som behöver börja bygga en styrelse men det blev väldigt bra.
Men?
Men, sen när postpandemin kom så hamnade vi, gensligt, i en ekonomisk kris.
Samtidigt som du vet, Ukraina blir invaderat, med det här stoppet till panel, till panelen, till Suezkanalen.
Det var väldigt mycket som hände väldigt, väldigt, väldigt snabbt och den externa väden hade lämnat precis och det var, ja men det var kaos.
Det är inte, det finns inget bättre ord för det.
Och då kände jag att det fanns inte pengar till att ha en styrelse för en bra styrelse kostar, en bra styrelse jobbar inte gratis.
Och vi behövde ta beslut nästan varje morgon, var vi var på väg.
Och vi var inte ens säkra på att vi skulle överleva detta.
Så illa var det.
Och då sa jag upp styrelsen så tänkte jag, ja men vi kör igång om ett år igen.
Men det har inte blivit av, utan istället har vi satsat på ledningsgruppen och att utbilda ledningsgruppen.
Vi har bokcirklar, prata strategier, så på något vis har vi höjt nivån på ledningsgruppen istället.
Men jag hoppas att det en gång blir en styrelse igen.
En styrelse har absolut ett värde, så tycker jag.
Från vilken nivå?
Du sa att du börjar redan vid 30 miljoner.
När vi omsatte 30 miljoner var det bara jag.
Ja och jag tyckte det kanske har varit för tidigt.
Det har du alldeles rätt i.
Jag tänker någonstans, Danne, om du vill gå över 100 miljoner.
Det beror på också om du är vd och om du är ägare.
Du har ett mindre behov av en styrelse om du är både vd och ägare.
Men om du bara är det ena eller det andra så tror jag att du ökar behovet av styrelse.
Ja men jag gillar det.
Låter rimligt.
Du har också varit med i Mensa.
Jag tycker det är intressant för det är ganska sällan man diskuterar intelligens.
Men detta var ganska länge sedan om jag förstår det rätt.
Ja men jag gick med 99 och sen är du livstidsmedlem.
Så jag är med fortfarande.
Men du har varit aktiv på jättelänge.
Men i början var jag väldigt aktiv.
Då ordnade jag oss med att det här är Helsingborg.
Det var mitt umgänge då på den tiden.
Jag ska för en sån disclaimer säga att jag gjorde det där testet en gång och då kom jag också med i Mensa.
Men jag gick aldrig med i Mensa för jag tänkte ska jag betala 200 spänn för det här eller vad det nu kostade.
Och jag får alltid tanken att det sitter 10 personer i ett rum och bara typ suckar och känner sig lite överlägsna och löser pussel.
Nej, inom Mensa tror jag inte man funderar så mycket på intelligens.
Vad gör man på de här mötena?
Man hänger och dricker öl och spelar spelet, kan vara fija med knuff eller monopol eller vad som helst.
Kan man inte spela något lite mer avancerat än fjärn med knuff?
Jo, kan man göra.
Är det bara att smarta människor ska umgås?
Folk är inte så intresserade av att bevisa sin smarthet.
Finns det inte alltid någon i rummet som bara är den där asjobbiga som vill visa?
Nej, de kommer ju bara på en träff och sen inser de att det här är inte klubben för inbörd och sprundrand som de kanske hade trott.
Eller liksom de prestigieföreningar och sånt.
Det är absolut inte det, utan det är bara människor som gillar att fästa.
Och det här är som, eller att hänga eller snacka.
Så det är vilken social klubb som helst.
Men jag tror faktiskt att man trivs bäst med människor som kanske ligger någonstans kring ens egen intelligens.
Man gillar att hänga med sådana människor.
Ja, jag tycker inte, alltså ibland kan man ju träffa människor som är jätte, jätte, jätte, jätte, jättesmarta.
Och jag har inte så mycket itbit av dem.
Och åt andra hållet heller, inte i någon längre period, så har jag fått någon utmaning.
Man behöver, det är skönt att träffa människor som är en själv.
Och det är liksom, en homogengrupp är bekväm, så kan vi uttrycka det.
Ja, jag har en polare som myntade ett begrepp, jag har inte allt kredd till Anthony Sastre här nu, men han myntade ett begrepp som kallas för omni-quote, alltså OQ, och det, han beskrev det som att ifall, för att IQ är ju någon sorts logiskt tänkande att förstå, men, och sen så har man emotionell känsla med EQ då, men på något sätt så, de människorna som jag upplever som väldigt, väldigt smarta, de är väldigt bra på att se samband, de är väldigt bra på att förstå att om vi gör så här, så kommer det här påverka, och det kan även vara emotionellt, alltså om den här människan mår dåligt, så kommer det påverka bolaget.
Så det är liksom inte IQ baserat, alltså det är inte så.
Men OQ är om ni, alltså att du förstår liksom sambandet mellan att den här saken händer kopplat till den här saken, till den här saken, och jag bara älskade det begreppet.
Jag kan uppleva att de människorna blir väldigt duktiga, de som har en hög förståelse för, Det sociala spelet, Sociala och även liksom, ah, fan, nu kraschade den här båten nere i Suez, eller hur trebelle kommer, hur ska det här?
Då skulle jag säga, det är IQ.
Okej.
Det är inte om ni tycker eller i OKU, utan det är IQ.
För det är precis det som är min styrka.
Jag förstår.
Att jag kan tänka liksom i fem steg framåt alla schackspel, så att säga, med många saker.
Men i OKU, det jobbar en tjej här på Gensom, hon är väldigt så, men känslomässig.
Alltså den personen kommer inte vilja jobba ihop med den personen, för de två kommer krascha och då kommer den här tredje personen och tycker att det här är jobbigt.
Så hon spelar ut sådana spel fast med känslomässigt.
Det är imponerande.
Vet de andra om att hon sitter här och spelar schack med dem?
Hon spelar inte, hon är väldigt, väldigt omtyckt.
Hon är också väldigt fin människa.
Det har varit väldigt kul om hon skrev prognoser och så visar hon dem två veckor senare.
Vad skulle du säga att man behöver ha en viss IQ för att driva framgångsrikt bolag?
Det tror jag.
Jag tror man behöver vara smart för att driva ett bolag, men det är bara en faktor av massor med faktorer som gör om man blir framgångsrik eller inte inom företagande.
Så precis som inom idrott räcker det inte bara med att du är, du kan ta boksning då, att du har uthållighet eller sådär, men du behöver också vara, du behöver ha låg kroppsvikt ifrån en till längden kanske just med boksning och du behöver ha långa armar är bra och du behöver ha bra lungor så du klarar uthålligheten eller en hundra meters släpare behöver ha explosiva muskler.
Det är mycket men framförallt en faktor som är jätteviktig det är ju pannben och driv.
För att bli framgångsfränkande inom vad som helst då är det säkert 20, 30, 40, 50 faktorer som måste samspela.
Där intelligens är en av dem vad gäller just företagande.
Men det finns många andra som är jätteviktiga.
Det viktigaste tror jag är pannben och driv.
Har du inte det så kan du vara hur egentligen inte som helst du kommer inte komma vidare ändå.
Ja verkligen.
Vad är dina största nackdelar?
Vad är det du saknar för kompetens eller drag?
Ja det är tålamod med dåliga prestationer kanske.
Men skulle du säga att om du hade haft tålamod med dåliga prestationer, hade ni varit dubbelt så stora då?
Nej men det hade jag nog inte varit.
Mm, jag vet inte vad det är för fråga.
Hahaha, ja men det är liksom.
Jag är till exempel slarvig.
Jag är bedrövligt slarvig.
Jag är dålig på, så om någon vill blåsa mig så skriver ett avtal och skriver tredje paragrafen, liksom lägg in någon jävla grej så kommer jag bara missa den säkert.
Jag vill att saker ska gå ultra fort.
Och jag blir rastlös.
Så det är min sämsta grej.
Jag gör många dåliga beslut för att jag inte har tagit mitt tid.
Du måste inte ha någon negativ.
Jag tycker bara det är intressant att se om man reflekterar över det.
Det har jag verkligen reflekterat de sista åren.
Att jag drar igång projekt som jag vet.
De kommer att bli jätte jätte jätte bra.
Men sen har jag inte fokuset att göra det själv.
Då går det inte bra för man kan inte lämna över en vision till någon annan.
Så det är nog det att man drar igång många projekt.
Det hade varit bra om vi sa att de hade dödats för länge sen.
Jag har sparat mycket pengar.
Jag måste också nämna, jag lyssnade på ett avsnitt, om det är i någonting som jag tror heter typ Parfimpodden eller någonting.
Parfimenalen.
Ja så var det.
När jag satte på det avsnitt tänkte jag bara fan det här, det här kommer bli smärtsamma 45 minuter att lyssna igenom.
Men det var faktiskt ganska kul.
Dessutom fick man följa din kollega i den.
Då pratade ni om parfymer.
Som ni pratade om parfymer, pratade folk om mat.
Alltså så här, jag gillar den här sortens mat.
Jag har aldrig reflekterat parfymer på det sättet.
Men då sa ni den roligaste meningen, jag har hört om parfymer, det är inte så stort utbud men det var väl roligt sagt, det var att ni tycker om parfymer som kräver en acquired taste.
Alltså parfymer som man typ ska lära sig tycka om.
Är det liksom en grej?
Ja, jag tycker att det är kul.
Ja, den här luktar skit första gången.
Men nästa gång var den lite godare.
Vill man gå runt och lukta så liksom?
Ja men det är ju att upptäcka någonting.
Det är ju en discovery resa på ett mångfald.
Man inser också att man blivit bättre och bättre.
Därför att vissa parfymer är ju...
Man behöver lära sig gilla dem och när man väl har gjort det så upptäcker man ju att de är briljanta som människor faktiskt.
Eller truffel eller kaffe.
Ja.
Eller viner är ju också...
Du vet det vinet man drack när man var 18 och tyckte var jättegott när man var 18.
Det är ju helt förfärligt nu.
Men...
Eller whisky också.
Rökiga whiskys.
Det var svårt att dricka när man var 20.
Men nu så nyter man ju av det.
Finns det liksom en...
hierarki inom parfymer?
Om du tycker om den parfymen, då har du koll.
Ja.
Ja okej det är så.
Ja det finns det skulle jag inte säga.
Du kan upptäcka vissa...
Så Axe Africa, vart står det på?
Det är så roligt att faktiskt det är en av dem.
Det är en av dem som faktiskt även nördar kan titta tillbaka och gilla.
Jaha roligt.
Och liksom aficionados kan titta och tänka det där, det där är himla bra.
Just Africa.
Ja men det finns det.
Framförallt gäller det komplexiteten skulle jag nog säga.
Man förstår inte komplexiteten när man var ny inom detta.
Man kunde ofta ha nånting som var, mm det är gott.
Och ny, det är en sån parfym man kanske kallar linjär.
Det händer om ingenting på fem timmar sedan.
Det är samma doft fortfarande.
Men en acquired taste i parfymer, och när du är på en viss nivå, då kan du ju se att en parfym hela tiden förändras.
Nästan var femtio minut så förändrades det som en fyrvackeritorta.
Puff puff puff puff puff.
Kommer att ha hela tiden nya noter.
Och ibland kan det då komma en not kanske som man vet att det är väldigt svårt att fånga i en parfym eller du vet.
Och då kan man bli imponerad över kreativiteten hos konstnären där.
Som man kan skapa detta eller fånga den och sätta den i det sammanhanget.
Ja men det är ju ett konstnärskap tycker jag.
Är det positivt, nu tänker jag att ni har några butiker.
De människorna som står i butiken och guidar folk, de blir ju verkligen den här sortens guider.
Jag har ju hört, jag kommer inte ihåg vad hette han killen som var.
Denne kanske.
Han hade jobbat med dig länge i alla fall.
Och han gick ju igång på detta, det var ju tydligt.
Hur är det att jobba med den sortens människor?
Det är så underbart, det är så så underbart att jobba med människor som är pensionerade och engagerade.
Och du vet, vi gjorde en medarbetareundersökning för några år sedan och nu kommer jag inte ihåg vad alla stapeln skulle vara, men den här stapeln engagemang, där slog vi i topp.
Generellt sett vi hade högt, vi slog i topp nästan i allt, utom en stapel.
Och det var stapeln, var är vi på väg?
Och jag tycker att alla är superengagerade, men ingen vet var vi är på väg någonstans.
Men den här sortens engagemang, jag tänker alltid på risker liksom, och jag tänker att du måste ändå ta affärsmässiga beslut, ja men vi ska börja sälja den här lukten.
Och jag bara intalar mig att de grejerna som ni säljer, som ni kanske drar in vissa människor på, eller som grejer, det kanske är tråkiga parfymer inom quotations, kan de här människorna bli irriterade då?
Om ni skulle göra mystery shoppers, kan du se att de typ inte säljer det?
Finns det en konflikt mellan att få vara passionerad och det ni...
Nej, för det första säljer vi inga dåliga parfymer, men däremot så har vi kanske instegsparfymer.
Men på den här nivån så är instegsparfymerna fortfarande, alltså det är jätte jättebra grejer.
Så de som jobbar i butiken, de är passionerade för att verkligen, alltså de gillar alla dofterna hos oss, och de är passionerade för att få kunden att hitta sin grej.
Och när du vet när du ser den här glädjanskunden att bara...
Wow, this is it!
Och så köper de den och går ut genom dörren.
Då är man liksom bara yes, I nailed it!
För den här kunden är jättenöjd, vet du vad jag menar?
Så.
Och det gör, det tänker alla som jobbar här, 100 procent säkerhet.
Fattar.
Du nämnde det här att ni har, vi har gått igenom lite olika trender, du sa våtrakning, nu var det parfymtrenden, vi ska inte hålla i detta, men vad tror du blir nästa sån här stora grej?
Nej, det jag vet bandar mig inte.
Jag undrar, jag såg en grej som jag funderat på, i fall vi inte gör en 180 grader sväng tillbaka till våtrakning.
Hela den miljö som är med räntor och inflation och konjunktur och sådär, det var precis samma sak förra gången vårtrakning var stort kring 2008.
Det är det här att det manliga kommer tillbaka, könsrollerna förstärks när ekonomin är tuff.
Är det så?
Ja, 100 procent.
Kolla Catwalken nu, kvinnorna har smal media, mycket byst, mycket hår, mycket naglar och behöver påfågla upp sig för att attrahera en försörjare, eller om jag liksom är krass.
Och männen, det går tillbaka till det välskrädda, det är 14 åringar som kommer i kostym ibland.
Det gjorde jag inte för tre år sedan.
Snikorbolagen har sin absolut sämsta år, detta året och förra året, någon som levererar fruktansvärda resultat.
Så man ser återgången mot att män behöver också utstråla familjeförsörjare för att kunna attrahera en partner.
Spännande, spännande, ja.
Och i det då, då ramlar du tillbaka i traditionella värderingar.
Och då är det rakning och liksom hela den biten.
Okej, ja det ser man ju på politik om inte annat, att man går mer mot en traditionell inställning.
Ja vad spännande.
Jag tänker avslutningsvis, du har ju varit, jag älskar när folk har varit företagare länge och man har drivit någonting länge.
För då har man gjort, då har man liksom lite mer insikt kring det.
Man är inte så naiv kring sitt företagande kanske.
Men du har ju varit detta i 20 år och du har gått igenom både lågkonjunktur och covid och mycket mer utköp och inköp och liknande.
När du ser tillbaka på allt som du har gjort här, känner du dig stolt?
Har du gjort dig själv nöjd liksom?
Varken eller skulle jag säga.
Alltså jag är inte stolt och jag är inte besviken.
Jag har gjort så gott jag har kunnat under de förutsättningar som man är given.
Vi pratade barn här tidigare till exempel.
Om man liksom vaknar fem gånger per natt och behöver byta lakan och blöjor och hela grejen.
Det har jag gjort nu de senaste 11 åren eller ja, typ.
Och behöver du vara helt uppdragig så det är sjukhetsbesök och det är ditt namn och detta liksom.
Så det blev ju bara så mycket lagt på jobbet.
Och det skulle nog göra mig besviken om jag tittar på hur mycket, på vad man hade kunnat åstadkomma.
Men samtidigt, så under de förutsättningar så är jag nog himla sålt över vad jag har lyckats åstadkomma faktiskt.
Jag förstår faktiskt precis vad du menar.
Jag kan också reflektera över det ibland.
Inte att jag känner att det är en waste, för det är inte så jag menar, utan jag är jättestolt över mina val.
Men jag kan ibland undra vad jag hade gjort, om jag hade vikt mitt liv åt detta, eller om jag verkligen gick in för det och inte var lika...
Jag kan uppleva och jag gissar att du har samma, att man försöker ändå vara en god människa.
Om man hade varit en lite mindre god människa, hur bra hade det gått?
Man hade kunnat göra en del deals som kanske hade förändrat eller snabbat på, eller om man inte hade de värderingar man har.
Det hade bara varit spännande att se vart man hamnade.
Jag tänker också, till exempel Elon Musk som har tolv barn, och han bor inte med något av de barnen.
Och så tänker jag ändå, men är han lycklig?
Ja.
Jag går igenom dagliga struggles hela tiden, men någonstans är det också de motgångarna.
Jag tror ändå att jag kommer dö en lycklig människa någonstans.
Som en komplett, men lycklig människa.
Exakt, man lever i ett fullt liv.
Och så är det väl lite grann så.
Sover man borta så tar det en dag eller två och sen tänker man fan jag vill hem och sova med ungarna igen.
Tack så jättemycket Jenny för att du var med.
Fantastiskt avståendet.
Jag är bedrövligt slarv, jag är dålig på det.
Så om någon vill blåsa mig så skriv ett avtal och skriv i tredje paragrafen, lägg in någon jävla grej så kommer jag bara missa den säkert.